je reçois maintenant le comédien gérard
lanvin pour le goût des autres le film
d'agnès jaoui jeanne lanvin bonsoir soit
alors on est content de vous avoir parce
que déjà au cinéma vous êtes quelqu'un
de rare alors en télévision c'est son
corps tirs oui non mais parce que je
n'aime pas trop expliquer mon travail je
le montre et les débats sur le métier
m'intéresse pas dire oui mais nous on
vous aime on a envie de vous le dire je
vous remercie pour ça tu vois alors le
goût des autres donc film d'agnès jaoui
scénario de djaoui et bacri alors je
connais pas je parle à nedjaoui là
excusez moi je ne connais pas ni bacri
j'étais bouleversé bravo j'ai tout ce
que je peux dire j'étais bouleversé on
s'entende ce film ça va durer 48 heures
l'histoire
je crois que c'est un film qui va avoir
un gros succès et plein de césar dans un
an voilà si je voulais leur dire parce
que c'est vraiment un film qui m'a
énormément touché je crois que suis pas
le seul d'ailleurs parce que beaucoup de
gens autour de moi que ce soit lisabeth
cas où patrice carmouze qui n'ont vu ont
été aussi très très touché par ce film
en sort pas indemne quoi c'est quelque
chose d'important
alors l'histoire en gros vous lui a
raconté que la réponse raconter la tyrie
non c'est un essai samse castella québec
criq est un industriel qui vit avec sa
femme il a un chauffeur qui échappe à un
garde du corps qui est vous parce qu'il
doit signer un contrat dont les
assurances demande qu'il soit protégé
iran qu il doit apprendre l'anglais
il rencontre clarac épreuve d'anglais
cannavaro est en fait au début fais pas
très attention à elle et un jour en
allant voir une pièce de théâtre où joue
une de ses nièces
il retombe sur elle joue bérénice et
très beau d'ailleurs on s'aperçoit à
quel point bérénice est un essai
fantastique
rien n'arrive à aussi anne alvaro et
externe et là c'est le choc des mondes
c'est à dire s'ils ont rien à voir
ensemble elle vit dans un milieu
culturel donné à tre lui y vit dans son
monde un peu difficile quoi et c'est la
rédemption par l'art lui les verts
rédemption réel ce qui est encore plus
intéressant dans le film c est qu elle
commence à porter un regard plus
critique sur son milieu et chacun prend
conscience non seulement de l'autre mais
aussi de 200 milieu voilà
voilà vous l'avez très bien c'est un
film sur le comportement et on les a
priori les préjugés qu'on peut avoir sur
les autres
d'où le titre le goût d eau d autres le
goût d'aller vers les autres et vous
vous êtes moreno devant sinon vous êtes
le le garde du corps engagés par les
assurances alors c'est un oui un garde
du corps qui arrive dans une famille
finalement parce que alain chabat qui
joue le chauffeur joue aussi le
chauffeur de la patronne un de madame
castella extraordinaire
c'est un type qui arrive dans une dans
une histoire et qui doit commencer à
s'adapter à cette histoire il se fait
profondément chez pascal ou l'autre
garde du corps est très chiant et
militer dans la police avant il était
dans la police il leur raconte une
histoire au début si l'histoire de la
tortue c'est à dire que de tortues de
dire que lui tu es dans la police où il
a donné sa dame parce qu'ils avaient un
gros bonnet voilà c'est un mec qui est
assez définitif sur céline comportement
parce que justement il a pris des coups
il a pris des coups et notamment dans
son boulot il ay là il a pris des
options qui n'étaient pas les bonnes et
s'est fait virer ou enfin s'est fait
virer parce qu'on l'a un peu poussée
dehors et donc il a un comportement
définitif avec la justice pour lui la
justice c'est de la merde c et il va
être à l'intérieur de ceux de ce film le
seul personnage qui ne va pas changer de
l'histoire il a beau aller vers
quelqu'un ça ne va pas lui suffire
il va il va se refermer et ne va pas
aller jusqu'au bout de cette aventure
qui pourraient le changer et à la fin il
apprend quand même que lui avait quitté
la police le jour où ce gros bonnet
avait été protégé que son son collègue
tortue lui était resté il trouvait que
c'était une trahison est en fait à la
fin tortue arrête le mec
ouais donc en fait est ce que ça va pas
dire un peu la morale de la sphère qu'il
faut jamais quitté le terrain et
finalement il faut pas baisser les bras
et que chaque ça veut dire non parce
qu'on peut toujours trouver de bonnes
raisons de ne pas faire les choses
finalement oui sinon vous ne seriez plus
de télé ni moins du cinéma là il faut
continuer à se battre il faut pas
attendre que les autres vous aide c'est
un parcours qu'on fait avec sa mentalité
il faut la faire accepter c'est tout
bête mais est-ce que vous finalement je
n'ai pas le sentiment un petit peu de
gérer votre carrière un petit peu comme
moreno gère sa vie c'est à dire de temps
en temps vous vous cassez là bas à la
baule et puis vous dites je m'en vais
j'en ai marre cinéma dans il faut être
clair avec ça j'ai fait des enfants avec
une femme que j'ai mené des enfants que
j'aime et je veux les apprendre ses
enfants je veux leur donner la
possibilité de me connaître aussi comme
papa comme j'ai cet avantage là c'est
que je suis heureux en famille
et donc je passe beaucoup de temps en
famille parce que ça me correspond et
c'était un désir absolu de ma part les
dix ans que vous êtes partie des dix ans
je suis parti là-bas j'ai des amis aussi
et je me dois de consacrer du temps ces
gens là parce que ça cesse et c'est mon
équilibre
le cinéma prend beaucoup de temps un
film c'est trois mois un mois de
préparation avant si on en fait de
parents savent à 3 par an c'est qu'on se
fout un peu du reste quatre parents j'en
parle pas alors évidemment le le
résultat des courses c'est que quand
vous faites un film par an s'il marche
pas vous l'avez vous le prenez pleine
poire et quand on vous en fait 4 vous
avez au moins la possibilité de penser
qui en a au moins deux ou un qui va être
retenu
mais est-ce que vous n'oubliez pas le
cinéma comme une combine le cinoche
m'est tombé dessus par hasard et les
utiliser comme une combine parce que je
veux pas devenir un fonctionnaire du
cinéma si vous êtes quand même un
rapport et que s'il m'a un peu on a le
sentiment des fois vous avez peur de
vous jeter à l'eau finalement non j'ai
sûrement peur de me jeter à l'eau met
fin en ce qui concerne mon travail mais
c'est vrai que c'est une combine à
partir du moment où je n'ai pas appris
quoi que ce soit pour le faire j'étais
fort hein j'ai aidé et martin lamotte à
construire un café théâtre qu'il entend
lancer une nouvelle fierté d'ailleurs le
point virgule et en cela je trouve que
c'est une combine elle m'est tombé
dessus c'est pas une raison pour
l'affermage la respecte au taf tout à
fait dit après après les spécialistes on
marche à l'ombre
j'aurais pu être entraîné dans le
tourbillon mais je sais relativiser
c'est à dire c'est pour ça que je dis ça
parce que comme si vous avez eu peur de
faire une énorme carrière un moment non
non j'ai eu la chance simplement de
fréquenter coluche pendant très
longtemps une dizaine
et j'ai vu ce que c'était que la
célébrité à des degrés énorme ça ne
m'intéresse pas moi je veux simplement
être acteur je voudrais être forcément
car c'est un comportement le star system
cema un métier donc je n'ai pas cette
fonction là à moi dans ma tête comme
étant le meilleur aussi aux césars etc
j'ai pas il pas envie de faire un
concours et et moelleux le fait d'eux
des tracteurs et si possible un bon
acteur me suffit largement
alors d'accord je vous fais débuté au
cinéma 177 vous n'aurez pas l'alsace et
la lorraine vous superbe
oui superbe collants blancs avec une
belle poutres apparentes et après bombay
à tous vos films et des films une
étrange affaire mais j'ai beaucoup
apprécié un bon film avec nice y un tir
groupé marshall ont des spécialistes on
en a parlé
et puis il ya eu quand même d'autres des
problèmes aussi c'était moi vouloir toi
je te lancer dans la coécriture du film
est enfin j'aurais aimé que ce soit la
coécriture du film c'était avec votre
votre wii
alors bon c'était un film d'amitié mais
oh j'ai été obligé de l'écrire parce que
patrice leconte qui était prévu à
l'écriture avec patrick de vol n'ont pas
trouvé la solution dans l'écriture moi j
me suis mis parce que fechner me l'a
demandé
sans savoir quoi que ce soit là dessus
j'ai quand même rendu 180 pages il m'a
dit c'est formidable j'avais pas de
recul je les crues jeu ceci dit je
revendique complètement ce film parce
que c'était un moment très heureux de ma
vie avec jennifer et l'autre problème
c'est lellouche quoi serviraient les
consacrer trois ans de votre vie il a
fait deux films avec lui vous avez fait
il ya des jours et des lunes et la belle
histoire il ça a été enfin la sortie
quoi ça c'est pas ça s'est pas bien
passé puisque quand on jouera qui
vouvoie voulu vous prendre pour les
marmottes lelouch lui a dit prends pas
lanvin alors que lui avait consacré
trois ans après c'était pas très sympa
voilà je pas [ __ ] la merde mais ces
problèmes courants déroulé avec moi
je suis quelqu'un qui dit les choses
parce que je n'ai pas honte à dire ce
que je n'ai pas non à penser donc sur le
sur le lascar en question bon j'étais
content qu'il vienne me chercher c'est
sûr à la résultante parfois forcément
convaincu par les films dont je me suis
tiré c'est tout bête par contre et ne
peut pas me reprocher l'ombre d'une
d'une erreur dans mon exactitude quand
je travaille et ce que je n'aime pas
c'est se venger à ce point là dans mon
dos donc je trouve que les mares manon
est un conte s'est bien passé d'ailleurs
c'est des films qui vous ont ramené
pascal parce qu'après le rôle de jésus
dans la belle histoire là c'était dur un
peu pendant un moment
ça fait claire heureusement il deux
films remarquables et le fils préféré de
nicole garcia qui est un très très beau
film et puis les marmottes cas qui a
bien marché aussi dont elle est une
hormone s'est classé noir mais ces
histoires anciennes et bien sûr il était
un peu déçu quand même par la faim le
côté famille du cinéma vous y croyez pas
trop s'il faut soit vous êtes plutôt
avec votre vraie famille à la baule
voilà m puis la famille du cinéma faut
pas compter dessus dans la mesure où
allait s'adapter c'est limité donc il
faut pas s'adapter une famille il faut
en connaître plus tôt plusieurs elle
existe mais c'est ce nom de par le film
d'agnès jaoui d'ailleurs cédé chapelle
c'est des machins autant être libre là
dedans et pas s'associer avec ce qui est
très bien dans le film c'est qu'à un
moment banal varrault clara lalala
l'actrice qui donne aussi des cours
d'anglais à un moment elles se rendent
compte que son milieu elle c'est ça qui
est bien dans ce film parce que se
foutent de la gueule de da creek était
un patron de pme c'est facile
à un moment elle se rend compte que dans
son milieu elle aussi à plein de
combiner que nous son copain ils
essayent le petit le petit peintre là
ils essayent de vendre des tableaux à
castella elle dit que c'est un peu
malhonnête quoi donc si c'est la
critique et des deux côtés c'est ça qui
est bien g20 film qui n'est pas comme
d'habitude
nollet dimensionnelle absolument celui
très ouvert l'intelligence à vos souris
à la fin du film quand même
bref la marine chabat russie les
corrections de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus